hello everyone welcome back to our
channel today we're going to talk about
the fastest most direct ways to learn a
new
language step 1
set language learning goals the first
step to learning a new language fast is
to set goals for what you want to
achieve you think about it this makes a
lot of sense if you don't set goals how
can you know what you want to achieve
and measure whether you have achieved it
or not
when faced with the idea of learning a
new language most of us feel overwhelmed
there are so many words to learn and so
many different ways to study
setting goals narrows your focus so you
can stop worrying about the details and
get down to business research shows that
people who set the right kind of goals
are more likely to achieve success use
these guidelines to get the most from
your goals one focus on specific
tangible outcomes set detailed goals and
focus on what you plan to learn rather
than how much time you plan to study an
example of a good goal might be this
week i'm going to learn 30 spanish
vocabulary words related to shopping
2. set short-term goals it's good to
have an ultimate goal the thing you
eventually hope to achieve but long-term
goals are too overwhelming to motivate
you
on an everyday basis break down your
ultimate goal into smaller bits and set
smaller goals for each week or month
three challenge yourself but not too
much
goals work best when they make you push
yourself but if they're too daunting
they can actually discourage you a good
way to get around this is to set goals
with a range of outcomes for example you
might say i want to learn 30 to 50 new
vocabulary words this week
the lower number in this range helps you
feel the goal is achievable while the
higher number allows you to push
yourself three
write down your goals
writing down goals helps you commit to
them
post your goals in a prominent place
like your bathroom mirror or home screen
of your smartphone the second strategy
consists of learning the right words
languages are made up of a shocking
number of words english for example has
between 600 000 and 1 million words
luckily you don't need to learn anywhere
near that many words to be proficient in
a language consider this
the top 100 words make up about 50 of
english language texts and the top 1000
words make up about 90
check out these lists of top 1 000 words
in these languages
by focusing on learning these words
first you can eliminate a wasted time
and increase the amount of information
you understand very quickly
tip 3 study smart when learning your
words you'll learn faster by using the
very best study techniques for example
one of the best ways to learn vocabulary
words is to use flashcards flashcards
help you focus on individual words and
allow you to test yourself which helps
you memorize new information
when you learn with flash cards follow
these tips to learn fast 1. try out
electronic flash cards paper flash cards
work just as well as they ever did but
electronic flash cards programs like
anki provides some great benefits by
using electronic flash cards you can
easily carry large stacks on your
smartphone or tablet and you can take
advantage of flashcards that other
people have created and made public
these programs also automatically change
the order of cards and use space to
repetition to gradually increase the
amount of time between repetitions of a
flashcard both of these techniques help
you learn faster and better
next strategy is about making sure to
guess the meaning of a word before
turning over the card flashcards work
best when you use them to test your
memory so don't be too quick to flip the
cards over even if you don't know a word
make a guess
next learn the translations first then
learn to produce the new words it's
easier to learn the translation of a
foreign word than it is to learn to say
the foreign word when you see its
english equivalent
start by looking at the side of a
flashcard with a foreign word on it and
memorize what the english translation is
later turn the cards over and use them
to practice producing the foreign words
when you see their english equivalents
you